e que a que foi a trabalhando porque que
a mída olhando porque é melhor porque
quer lutar e www da sony entrou no botão
salvar
acredito que o meu deus do céu eu disse
olha quem fala ao dar preciso muito
menos um filho de um sapateiro e mostrar
de que mais um episódio da nova série de
ação dizendo sinto uma idéia hoje fora
de casa em vídeos que se passa em tudo
debaixo d'água porque esse é um dos
grandes medos sabe quanto vocês vão à
praia ea maré tático shahira amin mata
línguas quando vai começar a baixar
vocês começam pelas rochas bastava que
padecem de projetar e sabe méxico
especialmente lá no fundo mas mesmo no
fundo do cuna do mar vocês têm durante
têm leis têm bichos feios pra [ __ ] e
é discutir momento e por isso que nos
provoca o barulho dos vidros muitos
músicos de brutais e vamos ver como é
que os cortes de pessoal já estamos aqui
com o vídeo pronto vamos lá em 32 burro
vai existentes nos faz parecer um espaço
no mar já não sei o discovery channel no
botafogo
este ano pelo homem tudo está ok
uma escuna morreram em mexicali sua
mulher e um pouquinho pois ganhando aí
eu nunca vi uma saia se ela vai no
primeiro cunha passa por cima vai fazer
meu deus não é morta
é muita coisa que bastava olhar o
botafogo por 1 a 1
meu instrumento até mesmo método está
pior do que coisas de tudo olha olha eu
sou eu caí isso não vai contra mim isso
não vai contra mim por isso tudo bem dá
que relaxa peixinhos é só peixinho de
uma falha que não tubarão é o [ __ ]
vamos pra próxima
ok pessoal com vídeo este vídeo tem
tubarões eu sei disso procure do
descrédito white shark 260 funda
os peixinhos admitiu sons pela boca e
não quer dar nenhum que 41 por
posicionar por cima e pra baixo e
uísques tem muita dignidade contou pra
mim ou não num trio
ele se prende à final dos jogos os
tubarões já não é assim tanto medo de
estudar
o extrato do shopping começa em outubro
o céu eo mar junto ao botafogo
o gol no entanto do gás russo foi só
isto ai meu deus foi tão emocionante foi
um erro e obrigado pelo vosso foi nesta
série de reação 260 taça mesmo brutal
muito obrigado pois na bunda todos vocês
que comentem e mais vídeos com as
esperam que vai junto ao conselho souber
enquanto não souber investir um like
falam todos falam tudo cuida atualmente
de ir embora quero discutir uma magia
para já vou chamou uma coisa tudo mágico
preciso uma campanha ótima tom para
solos ficar lotados em néon sem nada
agora parem vazia vou colocar a minha
mão dentro do cartola vejam que eu tenho
aqui roda assim